all right after Batman Tim Burton pretty
much had free rein to do whatever he
wants and he was like ah I'm gonna make
Batman my way so now we have Batman
Returns so let's review that one Batman
Returns all right so when Batman Returns
Batman does indeed return and now we
have two villains the penguin and
Catwoman and here's the thing about the
penguin right the penguin isn't actually
crazy as I understand him in the comic
books he's one of those guys that he's a
good businessman he gets rich he deals
weapons he does whatever he does his
crime thing but in the end you lock him
up in prison not arkham asylum because
he's not actually crazy he's not out of
his mind the penguin in Batman Returns
completely out of his mind he's played
by Danny DeVito and I cannot think of a
better person in the early 90s that was
made to play the penguin than Danny
DeVito he is really a piece of in
this movie he wants to take all the
firstborn kids of Gotham and throw them
into this lake of sewage and kill them
other than his motives he actually is a
vulgar bastard he's like 90% of the
reason that parents across the world
including mine were like oh yeah my kids
loved the first Batman what they're not
watching this weird mean penguins
bitin someone's nose blood shooting
everywhere he's talking about giving
this girl his flapper tranq
yeah he was a sick little weirdo and
there were a lot of parents who were
like no not for my kids and he's one of
the embodiments in this movie that shows
that the Batman franchise under Tim
Burton has gone from the Batman
franchise to the Tim Burton franchise
yes pretty much the Tim Burton show me
you have some weird elements in this
movie and then you have Christopher
Walken wanting to make the penguin the
mayor of Gotham City and Batman's like I
don't think so not while it's Batman
Returns and I'm returning as Batman and
then Christopher Walken's character Max
Schreck takes his secretary pushes her
out a window she splats on the ground
and then she gets resurrected as
Catwoman but you can argue a weird
resurrection element wasn't the first
Batman with the Joker he should have
died in the acid he didn't he just got a
bleached face and now he's back as the
Joker but this is a chick who dropped
about 20 something to 40 stories and
just smashed onto the pavement and then
cats brought her back to life and now
she has nine lives she has nine lives
you could take a gun and shoot her in
the face
eight times and on the night she'll
actually die you see the Tim Burton isms
coming through now as for Catwoman I
remember Catwoman just being like oh
she's the reason I hit puberty you know
you remember watching it you're like oh
yeah Michelle Pfeiffer best Catwoman
ever she's hot she's sexy and then
you watch it now and you're like she's
kind of a there's no better
definition to define her than absolute
bag she gets done with a
scrap with Batman she's feeling them up
and grabbing his balls or whatever I
mean granted Batman and Catwoman need
that sexual tension you know that energy
there's more to sexual tension than
licking the guy's face and grabbing his
balls after you fight him however she
does work for this weird Tim Burton
live-action cartoon that we're watching
that is entertaining as hell but the
definitive Catwoman that I remember her
being not so much as I watch it as an
adult don't get me wrong
Catwoman still hot as hell but I'm just
saying it's like that really you're glad
she's hot other girls like that
or you're like I don't require you to be
sexy or smart or anything like that I
just I need you to be you right now
Arkham City Catwoman that is the
Catwoman she's sexy she's tough she's
smart she's adventurous but she's not a
complete in heat I know a lot of
people are gonna be like no Pfeiffer's
the best captain whatever
don't let your nostalgia hold you back
from seeing what I'm saying I mean in
the end can you see what I'm saying you
know what I'm saying and Penguin has
this weird circus crew that he walks
around with he pals around with and they
cause havoc in trouble and they screw up
the lighting of the tree ceremony and
they're a bunch of weirdos but they got
these really cool costumes that guy on
the motorbike with a skeleton helmet
with the weird shifty eyes it looks
really cool but it is clearly Tim Burton
going sweet the change of the studio
bonds have been broken the studio gave
me free rein to do whatever I want this
is what I'm doing there's some of the
things go from cartoony to completely
unbelievable like there's a scene where
the penguin takes control of the
Batmobile right and he's controlling the
Batmobile in this little Batmobile
arcade thing that you're like where did
he get that like now it's just being
goofy now I do enjoy the vibe of this
movie though he's got that weird
Christmas Halloween vibe going on the
soundtrack is Grammy the soundtrack is
really good I bought it back in the day
it's still good now that scene where
Catwoman is just freaking out because I
don't know she's morphing into Catwoman
or Twilight ended or whatever reason
she's trashing her apartment that song
that plays in that scene still one of
the best songs of the soundtrack in the
end Batman Returns is pretty much a
testament that Tim Burton has never read
a Batman comic book in his entire life
but he can take Batman characters put
him in a movie with his style and still
make it a pretty entertaining movie I
will say Batman Returns is a good time
no alcohol required if you hate Batman
Returns because you love Batman
Laure and it completely butchers the
characters and Batman Laura it's fine I
understand where you're coming from I'm
just saying it's entertaining from where
I'm standing so have you seen Batman
Returns do you like Batman Returns I
think that's the big question here I
think people really like this movie
really hate this movie I don't know many
Inbetweeners at this point however you
stay in the comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more